for more let's get to chief Washington
correspondent major Garrett he joins us
now major good morning good morning
EU ambassador Gordon Sandlin what could
his testimony mean for both Republicans
and Democrats the Republicans have said
throughout no one knows the president's
state of mind well Gordon Silan will be
closer than any witness to date to that
state of mind why was he empowered to
have so such a large portion of the
Ukraine portfolio how often did he
interact with Rudy Giuliani why did he
interact with Giuliani why did the
president power Giuliani to create this
sort of side network of operations in
Ukraine what was the intent how direct
were the messages to the Ukrainians and
how much of this clearly and the
witnesses have established this
troubling maybe not impeachable but
troubling apparatus was set in motion by
someone at the direction of the
president and to what ultimate goal
major the Republicans and the president
have questioned both the character and
judgment of some of the witnesses who
are career public servants is that
strategy working does it appear well I'm
not sure that's the question is it
present proper are we comfortable with
this as a country politics is a tough
business but typically not for people
who work in foreign service or work at
the National Security Council and as
they've said all these witnesses work
for Republicans and Democrats but some
get a harsher treatment they get hassled
on Twitter maybe it's intimidation maybe
it's bullying but it's clearly hassel II
and their judgment is questioned their
resumes are questioned undermine subtle
suggestions they might not have full
loyal to the United States anyway if you
do one thing
testify unsympathetically to President
Trump but if you do testify
sympathetically that self same resume
all those same hardship positions that's
lyin eyes held up for celebration by
Republicans are we really comfortable
with a loyalty test for long-serving
public servants in government I think
it's a question the country has to ant
ask answer rather a major Democrats have
been using the B word lately as in
bribery they keep raising that issue but
the witnesses who testified I apologize
I'm losing my voice to feel okay but
it's me major
it's they've been using the word bribery
but none of the witnesses that testified
yesterday raised that does that hurt the
Democrats case do you think well they've
got to establish that they keep using
word it's in the Constitution it hangs
heavily over this process but you better
put some evidence on the table John
Radcliffe a Republican yesterday have
this kind of courtroom drama moment all
this testimony stacked up no where do
you find the word bribery bribery is
something that hangs around this but you
need a victim you need an actual cause
of something of value traded for
something else they're moving closer to
that the narrative sort of points to
that but the absolute proof on the
evidence of it yet to emerge and Gail I
wish you only kettles of hot teeth its
Grammy day I didn't want to miss Grammy
day major thank you very much always
hear from you measure and once again a
programming note Norah O'Donnell anchor
special reports from Washington during
this morning's public hearing and also
again tomorrow you can watch it right
here on CBS we expect the testimony to
begin at 9:00 Eastern 8:00 central and
you can find continuous coverage on our
streaming network that's CBS n